there Go tooke song do you have a good I
don't know what I've been doing Disney
songs lately just because I sound really
good on them for some reason that's like
a good I can show
you and then weirdly Creep by radio head
is like really good ballad for me has
someone else done that that is like the
go-to white man song well I'm not a
white man I know you're not but I don't
know why you CH you chose it I I didn't
mean to it just came up and I was like
wow I can belt on this song I think
that's why it is it's like no one sounds
bad it actually helps you sound bad you
can't really do yeah but I don't think
you can sound cuz it's like I'm a creep
it's like the feeling of it my mom's
friend cried while I was singing it she
was like I was like it's not that good
it's just she just never heard that song
I'm a Los
loser is it what the hell am I my 22y
old assistant is like I don't know what
the you guys are doing um